for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
in this video I really just want to
cover some definitions there basically
there's inner or core electrons outer
electrons and valence electrons and it's
important to know what these things are
what they mean so the inner or core
electrons are electrons in previous
noble gas configuration and completed
transition series okay
so let's think about the example bromine
so bro means condensed configuration is
written like this
so everything up through are gone and
4s2 3d10 and then for p5 so what are the
electrons in the previous noble gas
configuration and complete a transition
series that's basically going to be all
of the electrons that make up right
there right that's the everything in the
previous noble gas configuration and any
completed transition series so they're
all those electrons and these 3d10
electrons those are all the inner or
core electrons in the example of bromine
okay so that's just the definition there
now outer electrons the electrons in the
highest energy level specifically the
highest end valued right because n gives
you the energy level so keeping with
that example for bromine the highest
energy level is 4 so the outer electrons
in this case are these 4s 2 electrons
and these 4 P 5 electrons because the
highest end value here is 4 so all those
electrons are considered the outer
electron so it's got 7 outer electrons
there what's going on with valence
electrons valence electrons are the
electrons involved in bonding which is
basically forming compounds and we'll
talk more about that later but that's
just the definition of valence electrons
now which electrons specifically are the
valence electrons well for main group
elements which are the elements that are
numbered as a number and an A next to it
so Group 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 a 6
a 7a and 8a those are the main group
elements so for them the valence
electrons are actually the outer
electrons for main group Allah for main
group elements right if you know what
the outer electrons are those are just
the valence electrons so the number of
valence electrons that a main group
element has is equal to its group number
for example bromine bromine its outer
electrons are for s2 and for p5 those
electrons in total so it's got seven
right 2 plus 5 is 7 so that's 7 valence
electrons in the case of bromine okay
now for transition elements figuring out
what's going on with the treant over
with the transition elements in terms of
their valence electron it's a little bit
different their valence electrons are
their outer shell electrons plus they
are n minus 1 D electrons okay so what
does that mean well their outer shell
electrons are the electron the outer
electrons which are the ones in the
highest end value okay so the example
for vanadium V we've got all the
electrons up until argon and then for s
2 and 3 D 3 that's the electron
configuration for vanadium so the outer
shell electrons would be for s 2 so
that's those guys plus the N minus 1 D
electrons so if the N is 4 which is
what's going on here that's the highest
energy level and minus 1 would be 3 and
so those D electrons those n minus 1 D
electrons are also valence electrons for
transition elements ok so in this case
source there are five valence electrons
in the case of vanadium so a little bit
different when it comes to transition
metals okay anyway I really just wanted
to make this video as a sort of
definitions video so these are important
things to be aware of and I hope that
video helps to kind of make that pretty
clear thanks for watching if you found
that video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying